[Musique]
tu sais que je me suis réveillé tous les matins ma
première pensée est quelle partie de moi ne
travaille pas aujourd'hui et nous avons des passagers sur des
bateaux qui coulent lentement votre bateau est lent
je suis comme quand le Titanic pointait
vers le haut alors comment va ta vie amoureuse il est
je vois toujours euh comment s'appelle Triscuit
Tristan et non oh c'est dommage elle était
plutôt mignonne
eh bien nous avons beaucoup à dire tu sais
qu'elle avait la moitié de mon âge la moitié de ton âge est
toujours une vieille femme comme un humain à travers
le désordre jamais visiteur  oh Sandy hey kiddo
écoute je sais dieu pourquoi tu t'occupes de
moi Norman ouais tu es son meilleur ami
non je ne sais pas je sais mais ne
discute pas avec elle tu l'as compris
[Musique]
écoute moi nous '  J'ai tous peur parce que
c'est un [ __ ] de monde effrayant mais on s'en
sort parce qu'on est pas seuls moi
espèce d'idiot viens je m'aime tu es juste
déprimé ça va passer
ça va passer mon boulot ne me
comble plus
et  Je viens de mettre ma fille de 45 ans
en cure de désintoxication, continuez, vous savez que vous n'êtes
pas le seul ici à avoir des problèmes  Mme Oh,
quels sont vos problèmes, vous voyez
cette gentille femme Lisa, je veux dire, êtes-vous
fou de moi, vous m'amusez, je vais le prendre
, avez-vous une entreprise florissante.
continuer avec cette prostate
[Musique]
ça fait mal d'être humain ça fait mal comme l'enfer
et toutes les explorations dans le monde
ne font pas disparaître cette douleur parce
qu'être humain et être blessé ou la même
[ __ ] de chose comment était ta journée j'ai eu un
étrange petit homme met son doigt dans
mon cul tu me complètes je t'envie
[Musique]
toi